I'm here at the MTV movie
and TV Awards for Comedy
central.
And I'm going to interview
everyone.
Not even just the celebrities,
like everbody on the carpet.
Like that guy.
That girl shes not a celebrity I
dont know who that is.
She's probably like somebodys
bodyguard.
♪♪
Hey!
Who are you
interested to see?
Oh my God everybody
Everybody!
what a terrible
answer.
That was not
specific at all.
You want to touch
Zac Efron?
Yes I do!
Where do you want
to touch him?
In his face...
I dunno..
In his
face!
This is just going to be
a fun day overall.
Honestly you sound like you're
having the best night you ever
had.
This is going to be
the best night.
That's why I wore
my best outfit!
Okay okay I think it's red
enough.
We're just like the fast and The
Furious.
We're Fam....
I've never seen
that movie.
We've gotta make sure
everybodys
clean.
For the celebrities.
This is the biggest hand
I've ever seen.
For the celebrities.
It's for the celebrities.
I guess I'm confused
about your job.
Do you sell drugs?
No I don't sell drugs.
Okay, somebody told me.
You are confused.
I'm very confused.
Okay, well if you get drugs
call me.
Fair enough.
okay, all right
you guys are clean enough.
You can touch the celebrities.
You guys can't.
I havn't gotten to you yet.
These are five hot dogs!
Do you eat burgers?
Sometimes...
I try to cut down.
My red meat intake
because it's...
Boring...boring...
Sorry, oh...
I got a hair.
That, that's
just part of it.
Do you find
alot of hair in your...
I wished,
I made a wish.
Oh yeah!
what did you
wish for?
Hmm..just
world peace.
Every time...or?
Have to!
Didi you wear the
white so you could.
Do the wet t.shirt
contest in this rain?
Yeah obviously,
I've been working
On my abs...so
Yeah? let's see em.
We're Comedy Central
We'd like to
laugh at them.
It's fast,
it's furious.
That's how I
live my life!
Oh I've got to
clean this up.
It's a mess!
Oh noooo!
Oh no oh no!
Oh no....oh no..go!
run run run run run...